I had 5 years to get to 2,000
subscribers or something like that the
only thing I had going for me is I just
kept going it wasn't very good on camera
I didn't have any strategy I didn't
really know what I was doing I felt
insecure all the time I was introverted
and shy and like not a natural
Entertainer just stay consistent just
make another one just make another one
if you're always focus on the next one
you're making and not so worried about
oh my last one didn't do as well or
wasn't as good a thumbnail or whatever
like okay just like you sucked it
perfect make the next one keep going
there's always another one that you're
going to keep doing because in the
showing up you will slowly get better
you might be naturally talented amazing
but you will even if you suck you will
get better you will slowly get better at
the skill and opportunities will come to
you you can play forever right I mean
it's like you can keep doing this it's
not like in a year YouTube's going to go
away and now you're not going to be able
to make it I still don't 100% love any
video that we release right like I look
at like oh we could we could tweak that
always something that we can tweak and
fix and if you give me infinite time
with it I'll keep working but a video
has to go up today and a video has to go
up
tomorrow
Evan thanks for hanging out with me
today I appreciate it brother you came
to me thanks for making the trip to
Toronto absolutely absolutely you know
content creation has completely
transformed my life yeah my first time
to Toronto was 5 years ago Spin Master
do you know Spin Master the PAW Patrol
company sounds familiar yeah they make
Paw Patrol on a bunch of toys and shows
they hired me to talk to their marketing
team cool here in Toronto cool such a
cool thing and like I laugh to myself
because what are my qualifications I
played with a lot of Paw Patrol toys
okay so silly but it was awesome and I
love Toronto I love content creation
both places have have kind of chiseled a
place in my heart because like when we
talked on my podcast you ask what hat I
was wearing yeah and it was a New York
Yankees hat yeah and uh today's a blue
jay's hat blue J's hat I like it I never
thought I would go to New York City but
it's content creation that got me there
multiple times and uh it's kind of the
the same moment for me right now is why
am I in Toronto why did I go to Toronto
the first time content creation it's so
freaking cool I love it such a cool time
to be alive and uh I'm thankful for
people like you who are helping open
these kind of doors for people cool man
I appreciate you come up you're you know
you're you got a sore throat sipping on
some honey tea you got the The
Lumberjack shirt on Canadian the the Hat
we got to fix how you say Toronto though
there we don't pronounce the last t I
can do that not Toronto yeah it's
Toronto it's just ton there you go
Toronto I can do that yeah so if anybody
comes and he say and you say if you say
Toronto it's like oh where are you
from you say Toronto like oh okay now
you're local so we go okay it works I
like it when we talked last time I'm
still laughing because I asked you the
difference between 211 and
212 okay you're like what is that right
right right that's the freezing right I
remember now like what is that Justin 11
212 it's like me asking what's the
difference between 311 and 312 it's like
what are what are these numbers but it's
the difference between boiling and not
boiling right so and and we had a great
conversation about this but so often I
find people don't realize that they are
actually just one degree away from what
it is they want to
achieve what are some of those
differences that you've seen in people
that help them turn things up just that
one degree extra to go from not boiling
to Boiling cuz it's a difference between
a steam engine moving and not it's a
difference
between so many different things so so
what is it you've seen people do to turn
up the heat to take things to the next
level so I say two things the first
is just staying consistent on the thing
I don't know how many times it took you
to make a video before your channel
started to take off uh for me it was a
lot you know just I had I don't know how
many years 5 years to get to 2,000
subscribers or something like that it's
just the only thing I had going for me
was I just kept going right I I wasn't I
wasn't very good on camera I didn't have
any strategy I didn't really know what I
was doing I felt insecure all the time I
was introverted and shy and like not a
natural Entertainer but I just kept
going and so a lot of times the answer
is just keep going just stay consistent
just make another one just make another
one and I think if you if you're always
focus on the next one you're making and
not so worried about oh my last one
didn't do as well or wasn't as good a
thumbnail or whatever like okay just
like you sucked that perfect make the
next one keep going there's always
another one that you're going to keep
doing that's the only thing that I had
going for me in the early days and a lot
of times it really is just continuing to
show up because in the showing up you
will slowly get better you might be
naturally talented amazing but you will
even if you suck you will get better you
will slowly get better at the skill and
opportunities will come to you uh if
you're in the game but like you don't
get opportunities if you're just sitting
thinking about the game you got to be
there in the game and a lot a lot of
times we feel like we're just striking
out and striking out striking out but
it's like it's another bat and then
eventually you get a hit you know and
then you keep striking out and you get
another hit and you slowly get better
you can play forever right I mean it's
like you can keep doing this it's not
like in a year YouTube's going to go
away and now you're not going to be able
to make it so just showing up
consistently and for me it's having a
calendar and videos have to go up so
this is something I talk to creators
about all the time is for us as a daily
calendar for somebody else might be a
weekly or monthly calendar but a video
has to go up every
day even now how many years later 15
years later whatever it is I still don't
100% love any video that we release
right like I look at like oh we could we
could tweak that and we could change
that the int huge Point yeah it's like
we could there's always something that
we can tweak and fix and if you give me
infinite time with it I'll keep working
and keep working and keep working and
keep working on it but a video has to go
up today and a video has to go up
tomorrow so we do the best that we have
with what we've got and then tomorrow we
release another video and so nothing
gets in the way of the release schedule
so we haven't missed a video upload in
over a decade I don't know you can go on
the channel I guess see when the last
time we didn't have a a day of making
videos right now we do one long form per
day plus one short per day on the main
channel the Spanish Channel and the
Russian Channel and the other channels
have a different Cadence but a video has
to go up and so if you create a calendar
and say okay I'm going to do a weekly
video and it's going to it's going to
come out every Saturday perfect every
Saturday a video has to go up has to go
up e even if I was sick even if I had no
I've made videos with no voice right so
I yeah here he
is he's got his honey tea he's had his
cough syrup he's making a video with no
voice but I've made videos with
legitimately no voice zero voice and but
a video has to go up and this is where
we'll tell ourselves oh we can't we
can't do
this we shouldn't do this and our
friends would let us off the hook and
say oh yeah obviously you can't make
videos like no no no a video has to go
up and so I've made
videos with like me writing on cards and
just holding it
up I lost my voice and just pages of me
just holding it up to the camera because
the video has to go up and I filmed
through me breaking my neck I mean we've
got Danny here helping us film and Danny
was my camera guy when I broke my neck
and uh I had a concussion and I was
still making videos they weren't as long
I remember sitting there in in our
Airbnb and he turns on the camera and
like the lights already are I have a
concussion I can't see properly and I
could not go for as long as I would
normally would but I would still make a
video and a video had to go up and so
even if the quality is going to drop
because circumstances get in the way uh
or you're trying something new and you
suck at this new skill a video has to go
up and so if you just tell yourself that
a video has to go up no matter what and
then okay next week a new video is going
to go up so this one sucked cool like
next week a new one's going up if you
just stay consistent on the thing you're
going to start to win so that was the
first one the second thing I'd say is
then just say yes to Opportunities and a
lot of times when opportunities come our
way we find ways not not to do it not to
say yes not to follow through like
you're here you flew in from Idaho to
come here for this opportunity and I
messaged I had a few spots open today
and I messaged a couple people uh and
you said yes right like yep I'm in
perfect a lot of times people find
reasons why they can't do it right like
oh I have I have something else in the
way oh I have I have to be at my job I
have whatever else right and so
opportunities like that don't always
come along and so when they do what do
you do about it do you find a way to
make it happen or do you find a way way
to stay in your current situation right
um there's a guy who uh is based out of
Vegas where where you're originally from
and he messaged me and he this is a
couple years ago and he said hey uh I'm
starting a new show I'd love to have you
as a guest on my show uh I want to do it
in person it's like okay well if you
come to Toronto it's like okay like
okay like you're going to come here okay
cool so then the next week he he and his
camera guy hopped on a plane from Vegas
came here at this studio we filmed it uh
Travis I Know Travis Chapel or not but
um we filmed it here and then he flew
home like that night took the red eye
back home it's like I love this guy AES
and he's become a friend
since cuz I remember that and there's
other people who was like oh no I can't
make it because of this and that okay
cool I
mean moving on to somebody else right so
opportunities will come but they may not
be convenient for you right and so it's
like saying yes to the inconvenient
opportunity because like like this is
your chance to go to the next level in
your career so uh those two things just
staying consistent and then saying yes
to the opportunities even when they're
inconvenient I want to riff with you on
the consistency part a little bit um and
just focusing on that a little bit you
know we vlogged every day I don't know
if I told you this this is crazy
starting in 2010 we vlogged every day
for three years okay on two channels it
was nuts I had hair I had hair before
then right
beautiful beautiful locks
and now you got it up here you know you
got girls in the wrong places we we
didn't have a targeted audience we
didn't Target our audience at all it was
just like let's Vlog you know and
vlogging was big back then there were a
lot of big family vloggers we got
nowhere defeated crushed I hated my job
one day I'm looking at my kids stuff
around the house and I was like oh I
could film myself playing with these
toys so I started epic toy channel six
months later I could quit my job like we
were just killing it crushing it it was
awesome the difference for me between
failing as a vlogger for three years and
epic toy Channel which now has two
million subscribers over a billion views
is that target audience that metadata
that that niched down thing so I do see
a lot of content creators creating stuff
without a market in without a without
their target audience in mind and I
think that's a key component okay but
hold on let's go back to that when you
were when you sitting down and you're
gonna you're doing three years of family
Vlog and it's it's not working I'm so
excited for whatever you're gonna say
right now I'm so excited good when you
sat down to make the video about the
toys yeah that was not a wellth thought
out strategic market research doing
three months of analyzing channels and
thumb that was like a okay I don't know
let me make make a video about toys 100%
And I think that is where creators need
to
start we had we had the science in later
you didn't have all the market research
when you made that first video Zero you
just made the video for whatever reason
maybe you just loved it maybe this toy
was cool maybe you were frustrated with
your Vlog but like whatever but
something sparked yeah to say I'm going
to go make this video and it may not
even have made sense right like you've
been already doing three years of family
vlogging now it's like what you should
just keep do it's hard to like break the
streak yes right it's a big deal now you
lose just one day a lot of times once
people lose the one day the whole thing
just falls apart so you don't want to
break the streak and here you are making
a Tory review video like what are you
doing it's not it doesn't make sense but
you wanted to do it and then I don't
know what happened next like you loved
it you got great reaction the first one
actually didn't do so well I don't know
the the track but the science came in
later yes where a lot of creators start
with the science and they lose because
you're going up against people who love
the thing there's no passion exactly you
have to have a reason to do the thing
got it and then match it with the
science like you hopefully were
passionate about doing family vlogging
there must have been a core passion if
you're going to stay it for three years
but there wasn't enough science
connected to it like if you were going
to start that over right now you
probably do it way smarter than you did
oh yeah before you're you have more
contacts and knowledge and everything
else it's not one or the other it's both
right it's not passion or science it's
not head or heart it's it's both but
where do you start you start with the
heart you start with the passion and
then you figure out how to do the
science on top of it and I think that's
a pretty similar story across the board
right my channel was very similar you
know I'm known for doing profiles of
successful famous entrepreneurs the
first one I did though was years in on
my channel and was on Kanye West okay
and I did it on Kanye because this was a
couple years after his whole Taylor
Swift
Interruption Beyonce had the greatest
video of all time I'mma let you finish
whatever uh and a friend of mine Mark
made this blog post about going after
Kanye like don't be rude like Kanye but
this was years after like Mark you could
learn a lot from Kanye he went from
being a producer to being a rapper to
being an entrepreneur he won more Grammy
Awards than anybody in history at his
age wow it's like you could learn from
him and now he's a billionaire but this
is or well maybe not right now but he
became a billionaire and came down but
at that point he wasn't a billionaire
yet uh I like you could learn from him
you could learn from him and so I spent
the whole day researching Kanye to make
a top 10 video on
Kanye just from my friend Mark drer like
I had other better stuff to do that day
I had a production schedule other things
I was supposed to be doing but this
thing got me so passionate it was a mix
of like upset at Mark plus like okay
this needs to exist that I didn't expect
it to do well and I I threw away my day
to do this video just for Mark right and
it ended up doing really well people
loved it and they said can you do Jay-Z
and can you do Jeff Bezos and can you do
more people and this and then that
started this whole thing that now I got
market research now I got science now I
got you know 2,000 requests for
different people to profile on the
channel out of the that one video that
had no strategy it was a throwaway just
fun thing to do to show my friend Mark
right teach him a
lesson and that ended up working out and
so I love chasing down those ideas they
don't always work out though right so
was like for that one it ended up
working out for you the Kanye top 10 one
ended up working out for me I did
another one where was uh Shania Twain
Dance Challenge I don't you know shanai
Twain but she's a she's a famous
Canadian singer yeah and there was a
song that I had it I was playing it at
my office and it was a cooworker of mine
there someone on my team uh did didn't
know the song like how do you not know
this song this is a great song He's like
nobody knows this song ever this is like
a you thing nobody knows the song and so
I posted to my Instagram to
say okay Jason here doesn't think
anybody knows the song I love it what do
you guys think do you know this song or
not and it was like 90% nobody knew the
song like how do you guys not I started
I got upset now that nobody knew this
Shia Twain song so then I went to throw
away my whole day and make a TW Dance
Challenge where I I took the song sent
it to I just DM people all day long said
I I want you to make a video of
yourself singing or dancing to this
song and I messaged just I spent the
whole day again I threw my whole day to
do this Alex who's here with me in the
studio he he helps me this is a dance
studio that I own it's the largest dance
studio for salsa in Canada maybe North
America so Alex I'm messaging him like
Alex doing a shag 20 dance challenge
like what are you talking about I need
you to put on the song I need you to
dance to it you know dance most of these
people are like they have no idea what
they're doing I need you to he like I'm
at the hospital right now visiting my
mom or something I forget who was
visiting he visiting somebody I don't
think it was his mom who was it oh was
your mom perfect he's visiting his mom
at the hospital said Alex I need you to
dance with somebody find a nurse find
somebody on the street you have to Dan
and so he ended up finding somebody on
the street and they put on the song and
he started dancing and then I did that
for like a lot of people right just like
put this song on and dance we're going
to make this Shai Twain song go and and
we did it I don't know how many 30 or 40
people then submitted their videos of
shenai TW we put them all together and
then the messages that came in later
were saying hey Evan thank you so much
for involving me like I I haven't danced
since I was you know a kid I was so
nervous to do it but then you made me
comfortable like I want to do other
things outside my comfort zone now and
all the like warm messages when's the
next challenge nice like no that there
is no more right I don't want to do that
I mean that was a one-off that was a
upset about Shai Twain nobody knew the
song I don't want to be the dance
challenge guy right but I don't mind
being the famous entrepreneur learn from
guy it's like the point of that story is
not every crazy idea you have has to
work out right like was it worth it to
do the dance challenge yeah it was worth
to do I loved it that was great and I
threw away my day both times for both
events one project ends up BEC this
amazing thing that I buil my brand on
the other one becomes this oneoff little
thing that nobody remembers apart from
the people who you know were were part
of it and that's okay and so when you
have those moments those Sparks those
hits of inspiration just go do something
about it before your brain takes over
and tells you why you can't do it and
how stupid it is and what are you going
to do a dance challenge for and like all
of the things like I'll start next week
and then what happens next week you
don't do it right that was crazy that
was a stupid idea I had last week I'm
not going to do that it's like saying
yes to Opportunities back to what we
were talking about before and so you
need to start with the heart and our
brain often will tell our brain is
designed to keep us small Keep Us Safe
Keep Us protected and it doesn't agree
with the things your heart wants to do
like come to Toronto and do this do this
thing with heav like yeah but this
stupid I all of the reasons why my voice
I should cancel the flight yeah yeah
exactly work yeah right and that all
makes logical sense and like your brain
keeps you safe where your heart wants to
create something brand new and so you
need both but the big decisions are with
the heart and the starting point is with
the heart that's where creativity is
born right and then as you get going you
can use your brain to figure out do I do
I keep doing this how do I build how do
I inject the science into it so top 10
profiles yeah I love that all day let's
get smarter at it dance challenges one
and done right right but it gets back to
the story like it didn't start with
science it didn't start with target
market it didn't start with knowing your
audience it didn't start with creating
an avatar right it started with I'm
gonna do a a tour review I don't know
there's this dinosaur here let me do
this toour review and whatever sparked
the seed after that whether the video
did well or you got a couple comments or
was just fun to do or like I could do
more of this then you brought the
science in and that's how you blew up
you know a channel to having a billion
views right but it starts with the seed
of creativity that you just said yes to
and followed 100% something we talked
about last time in reference to my
podcast is you're asking what my value
prop was and if if and I'm was still
trying to figure it out at the time
still am and if I was just going to be
like a Larry King talking head thing or
what I realized a few days later I want
to be the advocate
for you know Mike Row Dirty Jobs he's
The bluecollar Advocate he's the guy
love him he's amazing I want to be that
guy for the Noller worker okay what's a
no Caller work work at creators in a
sense or maybe the dentist who doesn't
want to be a dentist he wants to run a
food truck or maybe the kid who is
really good at video games and he wants
to create I don't know an e-learning
course on teaching people how to be
content creators or just the out of the
box thing is no call or thing or you
just making that up I thought I made it
up and then I went to Google and I did
not make it up okay so what does no
collar actually
mean would have to look at essentially
that it's not blue collar it's not white
collar it's kind of everything else but
we live in the greatest time in history
in my opinion for people to pursue that
100% yeah it's so exciting so that's
kind of what I want to do with my show
encourage people to take the risk to I
didn't go to college no actually to be
truthful I did go to college for like 20
minutes right like maybe 30 but
I've always relied on me I've always
been the plan B and the plan a and I
want to encourage others to take the
risk yeah and so what's the name of the
show right now it's pretty clever I came
up with the first if you say so yourself
I came up with there's three words
unlimited okay I made that part up okay
with Justin Evans okay my parents made
up to Justin my grandparents came up
with the Evans
Park just my name yeah but that's what I
want to do is help people be become
Unlimited in whatever their Pursuit is
okay I mean I like it I like take the
risk better at least for where you are
now oh tell me take the risk take the
risk with Justin Evans oo because in and
say well what do you do you just said
take the risk I would encourage people
to take the RIS you said t the risk like
three times you didn't say unlimited at
all until I asked you the name of your
show take a risk I like it now you have
to take a risk to take a risk yeah I'm
I'm 15 episodes deep yeah but even like
coming here like you're taking a RIS
risk starting a new podcast you're
taking a risk having your you had all
these take the risk moments if you you
know my my Kanye story is taking a risk
and if you focus in on people who you
look up to respect admire want to learn
from and are telling their take their R
story that's inspiring to people and and
just your point doesn't have to be uh
just content creators it could be
whatever you need to do to pursue your
dream job
well it's it's insane I have I had a
client years ago who was making over
$100,000 a year filming fish tanks just
fish tanks live streaming fish tanks 100
Grand a year
insane that's nuts imagine explaining
that to our great our great great
grandparents you know in the future
people make a ton of money yeah on their
phone filming stuff like it's
insane forget great great grandparents
your parents
true yeah how old are you now 41 I'm 43
I I look 26 but I'm 41 you got you got
some gray in there man that's not
26 so I'm 43 it's about the same but
like the 41 that's not the same what 43
and 41 that's very different okay
perfect but look at your parents at
41 yeah what were they doing not chasing
down their dreams and goals probably
yeah unless you had serious outliers of
parents because it wasn't
possible it's not that you're so much
better than them you have more
opportunities it wasn't POS you have the
internet right you know they didn't
right at 41 right so the opportunities
are you're going to be sitting here and
flying to Toronto and meeting people and
creating people are going to pay you to
do this with content and advert like it
doesn't doesn't make any sense they're
in a completely different world so this
is where a lot of times when when I get
the parenting questions it's like well
your parents love you
probably probably they just they're
pilgrims like they're from A Different
World they don't understand what's open
to you because when they were your age
they grew up in a completely different
world and so they they they want what's
best for you but they're running it
through their filter and their world not
your world and what currently exists so
yeah your parents I me my parents at 43
was a completely different sure life
different world right it's
crazy that's a really good point so take
the risk like if you're talking about
what is the first step that people need
to take and whether it's people who'
have already done it or people who are
about to and you're going to encourage
them to do it I mean I keep thinking
about Danny he's my my video guy here
used to work at UPS is UPS I always mess
it up because say FedEx or some reason
and he tell he tells me afterwards dude
he said FedEx again dude it's ups so
he's working at UPS but he loves making
videos like he loves filming but he
sucks at it and like you know doesn't
have any paid clients and it's just
getting going and he's like working at
UPS and he's working in the back of the
hot truck and sweating his face off and
like hating life and just says enough is
enough I'm going to leave this stupid
ups and I'm going to start my own
business and I'm going to try to figure
it out without like six figure deals
lined up to be able to go off and do it
and he bet on himself and he made this
career and now he's got like all this
gear and working with big clients and
doing awesome projects and jobs and
commercials and tons of stuff cuz he
took the risk right so like stories like
that there's tons everybody has that
story but if you look to Danny now you
just see his website and his his work
and all the people he's worked with and
the commercials and like the fancy stuff
he's like oh this guy must have been
doing no like he worked as a UPS guy
sweating his face off in the back of a
truck hating his life I love it right
but like a lot of people everybody has
those stories most entrepreneurs
especially have those kind of stories
where yeah you you can uncover it right
yeah and and Danny makes a little bit of
content but but it's not his main he's
filming for people right so it doesn't
have to be becoming a content creator it
can be chasing down your passion right
and so that's a cool story like people
can connect to Danny's story much more
than uh Bill Gates or something sure
right because much closer come Danny
could do that and now he's got a team
he's got a successful company he's
loving his business and life a lot more
maybe I can too and I want to quit my
job as a whatever janitor instead of a
UPS driver right fun and I'm on Danny's
side UPS firstus FedEx and let me tell
you why what meaning what well let me
the UPS is better than fed yeah oh I
mean I don't know Danny come on it's
only because I I always mess up what
company worked at somebody told me FedEx
you know there's the arrow inside the
FedEx the logo right so like once you
see it you can't unsee it but there's
also the teaspoon inside of the E most
people don't know that like e is a
teaspoon because it's supposed to for
like how they measure like it's supposed
to be precisely measured so it's
teaspoons if you see the next time you
see the arrow look at the look for the
teaspoon so I always think FedEx by
default just because of that but anyway
it's ups but either way they both suck
you know like I don't think anybody
who's driving FedEx or UPS is like I
love my life this is great I get to sit
in these crazy hot you know uh trucks
developing or sending off packages like
being yelled at by people fighting
parking like it's okay but what do you
want to do so so that's your life now
awesome but what do you what do you want
to do what do you want to create what do
you want to build for Danny was I'm
going to become a videographer right or
what is the director what do you call it
cinematographer I'm going to be cinem
cinemat from from videographer to
cinematographer now right he's leveling
up I love it I love it but everybody's
got those stories right where if you
pick the ones that you're passionate
about and then bring on your guest you
can go see them in their studio right
take anny to another UPS truck watch the
watch the PTSD kick
in or just go to their Studio go to
their space and see that everybody will
have some kind of story of you know if
they if they can remember a story right
it's so inspiring too because everyone I
don't want to say everyone but most
people it seems are dissatisfied with
their job if you go back to what we
talked about at the very beginning what
did I say was like be consistent and
then seize the opportunity even when
it's inconvenient right like that's
taking a risk yeah like saying yes to
the opportunity even though it doesn't
make any sense and your brain is like
fighting you don't do this stay with the
job stay at UPS you know it's hot but
you're making money you have to pay rent
like you can you have a paycheck right
versus I'm going to go and seize the
opportunity to take the risk right side
note years ago Danny will appreciate
this I worked at a Distribution Company
and we had to hire either FedEx or UPS
and they both wanted our contract so
what I did was I mailed myself
eggs to my house in Boise and then my
parents house in Las Vegas using both
carriers whoever broke the fuel STS won
okay and how many did they break I don't
remember the count but UPS one okay yeah
just well don't cheers him for UPS he
doesn't like
up I'm probably the only guy who ever
brings up UPS around Danny anymore
anyway
so and that was a job I hated so content
creation got me out of it yeah there we
go full circle that's awesome I love the
I love to take the take a risk take a
risk with justtin Evans I like that yeah
I think I'm G to go with that
good yeah I mean it's your words yeah I
didn't even realize it when you play
back you can see you said it three times
before we even talked about it right
like take a risk right I'm dying to know
about the studio okay you own the studio
MH dance studio what happens here we
teach dance
okay so uh this is not a
very Evan comical business sure like
brick and mortar right teaching dance I
like that's why I'm surprised yeah I
like online I like scale I like you this
location is killer yeah I mean you don't
really know the city that well I don't
think but yeah it's it's on the subway
line it's close to the biggest highway
in the country Young Street is the is
the biggest street in the country uh and
it's young in 401 almost so it's it's
close uh you know free parking on the
ground and vibrant area but why did I
why did I do this so I have um I was a
student here I never learned a dance
growing up I don't know if you ever
learned to dance growing up uh my
mother's Italian so there's a dance in
Italy called the Tarantella which is a
this a folk dance and I never learned it
because I was born in Canada so Italians
learned to dance growing up but in North
America like we don't nobody knows how
to dance growing up so I got to
University and I wanted to dance and so
my girlfriend at the time went and we
signed up for ballroom classes and I Lov
this like oh my God I get to learn how
to dance and she hated it so we we
dropped out because they didn't want to
make her do something she hated but you
kind of need a partner for Ballroom yeah
so when we broke up like oh I can go
dancing so I picked up
salsa and uh salsa is much different
than much the difference with salsa and
in BM is salsa is a street dance uh and
it's very social so you don't have to
have a partner most people who come to a
class don't have a partner it's like 75%
singles 25% couples some people come for
date night whatever most people come by
themselves and you rotate so you learn
something and then you'll switch
partners and learn something and switch
partners and you get to know all of the
opposite gender in the class and none of
the same gender right so if like you're
guy come to class you're single you get
to meet all the women in the class and
you don't really know the guys but you
know who cares they're they to meet the
women and have some fun and it's much
more uh uh conducive to meeting people
than going to a bar or club or whatever
else and you get to work through
problems you know like you get to you
get to see how do you learn something
with this person so you're presented
with a challenge of you have to learn
this move how do you collaborate and
work together and you see some couples
already yelling at each other it's like
you you didn't move your hand fast
enough and it's like well like if you're
stressing out over this imagine real
life right so uh so I love learning and
then the original owner of this
business um wanted to not be involved
anymore he wanted to go and pursue a
career in acting and so I said okay I'll
I'll I'll take it over um I met my wife
through the business no way and so I
didn't want it to go away right like it
was too important to this community it
was important to me personally because I
met my wife and it was important for the
community and so like okay I will I will
take it over I will install uh a manag
who I'm going to train to be an owner
that became Alex and uh that's why we
have it now it's still fun like we come
we come for our weekly parties um Alex
runs the business U Almost 100% on his
own um I mentor and and train him and
Coach him and answer questions and I
come to dance at the parties that's so
cool and it works for stuff like this
because every so we're in a we're in a
mall here in Toronto and every other
store is open during the day you know
it's it's what 10:30 on a on a Wednesday
morning we're closed because nobody's
taking a dance class at 10:30 on a
Wednesday morning right we open up when
everybody else closes down so all these
other stores are closing down 5 o'clock
six o'clock that's when we start to open
up because people come for dance classes
so it also doubles as a as a film studio
during the day whenever I need to film
some
content it works that's awesome I love
it I love it and again the locations
killer give the movie theater upstairs
thinking about taking a risk right
Alex's story too he went Alex was a
student here and was the worst student
here almost like almost the worst
student here he he nodded he's like yeah
yeah yeah he he he got held back we
don't hold people back in class you have
to be new level of bad to be held back
so we have six
levels uh as you work your way up and a
level will take about a about 3 months
to complete and he got held back twice
every level every level so you got held
back a lot and again like 1% of students
get held back less than 1% like you have
to be new level bad in his life he was
he was all over the place he like wanted
to be a cop but then didn't pass the
test properly and so was a security
guard and was a uh in salesman walking
door to door trying to convince
businesses to buy interact machines and
all it's like all over the place slowly
he got better he's back to consistency
like he was the worst but he just kept
showing up it's like okay I suck I I'll
do the class again right I'm going to do
level two again I'm going to do it again
perfect he just kept so it might have
taken him twice as long compared to a
regular student and he still wasn't as
good as them but he just kept showing up
to get to the point now where he is the
head instructor and everybody's
following him wow right and looking at
how good he is when I asked him to join
the school to to basically be my partner
in running this he
was engaged at the time already had his
career in like his career and interact
sales or whatever but it's like getting
this getting this thing going and it's
like this is a risk right it's like okay
you're gonna you're going to leave this
path of sales where there's a lot of
upside and if you get good at it you can
find tons of potential to come and run a
dance studio right and most dance
studios don't make a lot of money most
dance studos are run by artists who can
kind of just barely support themselves
where this this facility alone is uh is
you know six figures in rent right so
it's like it's it's it's costly to run
this thing right um so it was a risk I
remember I met with Alex a couple times
over like late night uh walks outside to
talk about it and I don't want to force
anybody into something that's not a fit
for them talk to his fiance at the time
and like getting her blessing and seeing
what making sure everybody would be
happy and then he decided okay I'm going
to I'm going to take the risk and I'll
say yes and that was I don't know 7
years ago I don't know how long ago that
was N9 years ago wow you know and so now
like biggest Salsa School in the country
maybe again North America they lots of
upward growth potential what we're
creating see otherwise now he'd be who
knows selling some other interact
machine door too somewhere hating his
life right like taking the risk right so
again but you don't know because when
you look at the website you come through
the studios looks successful so if you
came at night you'll see a whole bunch
of students here dancing having a good
time you'd assume Alex grew up and was a
great dancer and learned this all his
life and he like no he sucked he was the
worst right like the worst and this is
why I love uh for YouTube creators kind
of bringing it back to creators don't
delete videos on your channel okay
that's good right so you can go back and
watch the videos on my channel for me my
first video
was April 2009 I think but I opened my
channel November 2008 wow so how often
do we like oh I'm going to get started
right and it took me whatever five
months to even launch my first video and
my first video was I wanted to be
perfect so I had my friend Mark the same
guy I made the Kanye video for he had a
video company so he came and filmed me
and made it perfect and I'm sitting
there in my suit and my tie and like
trying to memorize my lines and it took
over a day to make one video but then
the future videos like it was just me
and I I filmed out of my house I filmed
with terrible lighting I filmed but I
didn't delete them you can go watch them
because I think showing the journey is
important I agree yeah I don't know if
there's any videos of Alex do you have
any videos of you sucking dancing like
level one level two that'd be great to
actually see I have to dig deep you
should you should dig deep and find that
stuff not for this show but for you Alex
personally because he'll tell people in
the class I was the worst student but
you don't believe him sure because you
look at him now and he's great at
dancing and then you think there's no
way you sucked like no no watch watch
how much I sucked watch me like fall
over trying to do a turn or whatever
right see how awkward I was in getting
going and follow this process yeah it's
like you can do it too but even if it's
not like a a a process that is laid out
even just continuing to go that it's
possible Right like watching Alex suck
and this is where your show can come in
right like watching Alex suck I being a
dancer to then owning the largest dance
school in the country for salsa for the
dance of his choice and being the head
instructor and teaching at Giant events
to be able to do that somebody watching
the show may not want to be a dancer but
inspires them to go take a risk on the
thing they want to do right and
expecting to suck at the beginning and
that's okay like a lot of times people
will start something and suck and then
stop like oh my gosh I suck at this so I
guess I I guess I shouldn't do this
anymore like no you try One Thing Once
like why do you expect to be great out
of the gate on this thing right just
expect the suck and so telling those
stories of people taking a risk even if
there's no process to follow ideally
like if somebody's in your industry
follow the process you have a model to
look at but even just the willingness I
think if you're looking at taking a risk
it's just the willingness to say yes and
the willingness to try and the
willingness to to suck at the beginning
and to just keep going and not hide it
or delete the old videos or anything
else because you think about you know
now if you look back and say well look
at my first videos you can show how much
you suck too which is more of an
inspiration versus everything you did
was perfect right away that's not
inspiring no not at all so don't delete
your first videos If it sucks awesome
cuz the you in five years is going to
look back and be grateful that you kept
those videos up and for people to watch
your journey along the way yeah I say
every six months you should if you're
doing it right you should look back
every six months and say that sucked
that sucked yeah because you're just
getting better and better and I think
the key difference
is is between that sucked and I suck
right it's not that you suck you just
don't have the skill right you don't
suck as a human right that's what we
then interpret it as like oh I don't I
can't do this well so then I suck and we
feel bad as people that we don't have
the skill so we suck as humans as
opposed to no I just don't know how to
do that thing yet and the fact that I'm
willing to try is an inspiration like
I'm amazing that I tried that thing and
sucked at it right fascinating I want to
ask you before we wrap this up you've
rubbed shoulders with so many incredible
people Tony
Robbins sad Guru I mean so so many
incredible people is there a piece of
advice or wisdom or nugget or favorite
thing you've heard from any of these
people you've rubed shoulders with
that you think's worth sharing I'm
trying to I'm trying to not give you
just a standard copout answer who I mean
I've met a lot of people been I've been
grateful to have you know profiled some
of these people and now I'm hanging out
with them it's shocking how many people
you've been able to connect with it's
very inspiring I think it's all doable
right again like I just kept doing it I
just kept I just kept being in the game
I look at Tony for example Tony was my
first big interview uh when we did the
profile like a top 10 on Tony he put it
on his YouTube channel he his team right
and Tony's not probably going in there
changing his homepage and like oh Evan I
love this guy this you
know but his team like featured it on on
the homepage of their YouTube page and
uh they were grateful that you know I
made this
compilation and I I stayed in touch and
brought value to their team a couple
years later of just bringing value they
said hey Tony's doing a a book launch
and he'd like for you to be one of the
people that he does an interview with
what like like yeah I mean I'm sure and
he doesn't he at the time he didn't like
doing online he still prefers face to
face but it's become a lot more
normalized now but he was only picking
like three or five people period to do
online with so I was one of the I was
one of those people because I i' helped
he probably didn't even know who I was
right like I'd helped the team and they
saw my audience growing so cool like oh
my God if I get Tony Robbins and there's
the what am I gonna ask him and then
also that's gonna help my business so
much I can get other people on the whole
week leading up to it I was a wreck like
what am I going to ask Tony Robbins I
couldn't sleep well I couldn't focus on
any other task and then it got to the
day of like here we are okay you know
breathing exercises trying to calm down
we're going to have this thing in a
couple hours and then I got a message
from his team saying sorry Tony can't
make it got some
some emergency or whatever and that
happens too right I mean like at the
time I was devastated it's like oh my
God he hates
me whatever but but that's very common
trying to organize these kinds of things
but we let's do something else you know
we'll figure out something else it took
another one or two years of following up
wow to get Tony to come back on not
anything against Tony right again he's
busy he's got other stuff uh but it's
just a consistency okay I keep reaching
out and not just saying saying hey is
Tony ready hey is but trying to bring
value trying to help trying to give them
YouTube advice trying to help however I
can to then he finally came back on
right and so now I'm like five years
deep in on this relationship before even
having him on for the first time right
but that interview went great and he's
been on you know two or three more times
since then and then that led to whoever
Matthew MC con or deac Chopra or sad
Guru or Gary ve or whoever to come on
and then the Snowballs starts to to
build but it was a lot of work to get
the first one in and so just most people
they give up along the way because it
gets too hard they get they get Delta
blow like that on the day of like I was
so nervous on the going in for the whole
week that I like was secretly hoping
they would cancel so that I didn't have
to disappoint like what if I asked the
wrong question one if I'm not a good
interviewer right but the only thing
worse than than doing the interview and
it Su is is not doing the interview
right and them canceling which happened
so it's led me
to create a lot of these relationships
but just it was never part of the plan
it was just I'm trying to help I'm
trying to
serve you know you're doing the podcast
you'll end up talking to a lot of your
Heroes and mentors if you want to give
them advice give them feedback help them
with whatever they're trying to get out
to the world right now and stay in touch
so again that led to me being able to
meet amazing people that
I never thought you know I'd be able to
meet to just read about their books or
watch their videos in terms of advice
Brendan bashard gave me a great piece of
advice so back to kind of taking a risk
and saying yes to An Inconvenient
opportunity I was speaking on Brendan's
stage and Brendan doesn't bring in a lot
of outside guests so for that event it
was me and Eric Thomas and that was it
for the whole event it was him and his
friends teaching the rest
after the event he said hey I'm going to
be doing my own little Mastermind at my
house it was in Puerto Rico at my house
in uh in a week do you want to hang out
there's no there's no cost it's just me
and my friends and we're going to hang
out at my place and just help each other
wow she like
yeah sure oh yeah I guess and his
friends are like Lewis how and Russell
Brunson and Jay Shetty and Tom Bilu and
Mel
and like all the content creat in my
space they're all big names and thought
leadership
entrepreneurship but it was it was going
to be in a week and they all use iPhones
to connect and I didn't have an iPhone
at the time so I called my wife Nina I
was by myself in Puerto Rico because
supposed to go home the next day and I
told her okay so change of plans you're
going to fly down to Puerto Rico we need
to extend our stay an an extra week and
a half uh you need to buy two iPhones or
you need to buy an iPhone she bought an
extra one for herself
but you need to buy an iPhone for me so
I can communicate with these guys and um
yeah you know get on the first flight
that you can so like I didn't even know
what I had planned for that week I
didn't even know what she had planing
for the week but it didn't matter right
like whatever can be rescheduled and
reorganized and pushed aside and so I
get there on day one at Brendan's house
and he tells me I need to make sure you
need to make sure that you ask for
something cuz you're always pouring in
other people and giving but we don't
know how to help you interesting so you
have to ask like you got to when it's
your time everybody his format was
everybody basically gets 20 minutes we
just sit around this giant table that
he's got and everybody gets 20 minutes
and so like what do you want help with
and then whoever's turn it is they ask
questions and everybody just kind of
pours into them right likees I need you
to ask wow I have a hard time asking for
things you know and still do sure I
don't want to be like that sales guy
who's just always saying like what what
can you do for me instead of the other
way around uh so that's a that's a piece
of advice that really helped me he told
me at the right moment because we were
just a to sit down for day one and I
probably would have defaulted to scared
Evan afraid to ask for anything and just
bring value and just help but never ask
and so that little bit of advice in the
at the right time really helped me and
at the time I was doing a book launch
built to serve and I ended up asking
everybody to take a picture with me for
the book nice and I didn't even have my
book ready yet I had the manuscript but
it didn't have like a actual Galley and
so I also asked Nina Nina does a lot uh
to print off a um the jacket of the new
cover nice and my first book was called
your one word my new book was called
buil to serve and so we wrapped my first
book with the second book and and we
took
pictures with the book Brendan gave me a
piece of advice of have people read the
book so read a section of the
book and have them read like a passage
from the book that is relevant to what
their message is so I asked would you
would you do that for me Brendan right
I'm asking he's like yes like okay great
but I don't have a copy of the book so I
went through my
manuscript the new one and wrote out I
found like the passage that I think
would be relevant to Brendan and then I
found the blank page in my year one word
book and I Han wrote it tried to be as
neat as possible so that he could read
the new passage that's in my old book
right with the new cover right right but
I would have been too afraid to do any
of that stuff if he hadn't told me like
you need to make sure that you ask for
something something right and so that's
still a lesson that I have to keep top
of mind because uh yeah I still don't
ask for help when I need to hey same
here guilty I totally get it I totally
get it Evan thank you again for the
invitation to Toronto there it is here I
love it Blue Jays for days here we are
black on got my Canadian Lumberjack
shirt I'm ready to go I'm ready to go
like this is amazing cool man like my
home I love the first episode uh love
that you came up for round two and super
excited to see where you take take a
risk with Justin Evans I'm changing the
name it's amazing thank you again to see
me coaching another entrepreneur
one-on-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I remember talking to my dad and
telling my dad as a little girl when I
grow up I'm going to be an actress I'm
going to be writing and every report
card came with she talks too much